hey 42 here the history of the computer
goes back further than most people think
the very first automatic mechanical
computing device for example was built
in 1822
by English polymath Charles Babbage
admittedly the difference engine as it
was known was pretty basic by today's
standards it was powered by a hand crank
for a start
while Babbage's device was capable of
automatically computing values for
polynominal functions by 1837 mr.
Babbage had drawn up plans for an even
more advanced kind of machine the
analytical engine as it happened this
was to be the first ever design for a
general-purpose
programmable computer and when Ada
Lovelace the only legitimate child of
one of the greatest English poets in
history and full time reg Lord Byron
wrote an algorithm for this theoretical
machine she became the first computer
programmer in history sadly and despite
mr. Babbage working on this device on
and off until he died in 1871 he was
never completed but the design was so
groundbreaking that Babbage is known
today as the father of the computer and
what a proud father he would be if he
were still alive today he definitely
isn't by the way you can go see half of
his pickled brain in the Science Museum
in London since his death Babbage's
metaphorical electronic offspring have
changed a world beyond all recognition
despite the famous prediction of one
time IBM CEO Tom Watson who in 1943
estimated the total global market for
computers would stretch to around five
yes he meant a global demand for five
individual computers there are now for
us to be more than two billion of the
things in homes and offices around the
world if Charles Babbage truly is the
father of the computer
he has spread his seed far and
of course the kinds of computers were
familiar with today of the digital
variety and these arrives on the scene
in the 1930s around a hundred years
after Babbage's mechanical difference
engine was built in the 90s since the
leaps forward that have been made in
computing frankly astonishing as you may
have already heard the Apollo 11
spacecraft that brought Neil Armstrong
and his fellow astronauts to the moon in
1969 was about as powerful as a modern
calculator fifty years later a common
piece of tech that most of us used daily
to stay in touch with our friends and
generally piss about the smartphone is
quite literally millions of times as
powerful these exponential increases in
computing power we've witnessed are
broadly described by Moore's law named
after Intel co-founder and one-time CEO
Gordon Moore which states that the
processing power of computers doubles
roughly every two years but the biggest
driver if moore's law has been our
ability to shrink the physical size of
key components in our computer
processors particularly transistors
year-on-year the smaller you can make
your transistors the more you can
squeeze onto your chip and the more
computing power you have at your
disposal measured by computer scientists
as flops or floating-point operations
per second the problem is the smallest
transistors today are just a few atoms
across pretty soon smaller just isn't
going to be an option manufacturers are
coming up with clever new ways to keep
processor power rising but it's becoming
increasingly expensive and challenging
to do so which is why for the first time
in 50 years or so Moore's law no longer
applies exponential gains in processing
power
becoming a thing of the past this
doesn't necessarily mean we're reaching
peak computer but it does mean that
we're no longer making the kinds of huge
strides forward that have powered many
of the technological and scientific
advances humanity has achieved in recent
decades now you might be sitting there
thinking to yourself whether we actually
need more computing power after all if
we could fly to the moon on a glorified
pocket calculator the most powerful
computers of today should be able to do
pretty much anything right so long as we
have enough of them actually not so much
the most powerful supercomputer in the
world today is IBM's Summit it's the
size of around two basketball courts and
uses a hundred and thirty six miles of
cables it's capable of executing and
when Tilian operations per second a
number that sounds like it was made up
by a five-year-old to win an argument
and it's being used to push back the
boundaries of human understanding in
fields like energy AI and healthcare all
very impressive sounding but there are
things even summit can't help us with at
least not unless we have a spare few
million years to leave it running
certain mathematical problems are just
extremely resilient to solving by
classical computers even really big
shiny ones like summit the most commonly
wheeled out example is prime
factorization finding two prime factors
of a given number make that given number
larger north and classical computers
simply aren't up to the task now
factoring large numbers might seem like
a fairly arbitrary thing to want to do
with the world's most powerful computer
I mean I just like to know can it run
Crysis but it just so happens that the
fact it is very very hard to solve these
problems with any kind of regular
computer is one of the foundational
principles of Internet Security but you
can make sure you're already two steps
ahead of the game by vastly improving
your personal security with dashlane you
have kindly spots
today's video the best way to protect
yourself against hackers spammers and
other online threats is by using a
leading password manager and all-in-one
security suite - Slade he will store all
of your passwords in a super safe way
without ever having access to them or
allowing anyone but you to view them -
Lee creates strong and unique passwords
for all of your online accounts and also
fills them so you never have to click
forgot password ever again and you don't
have to sweat about the extremely rare
chance that dashlane could be breached
because - lanes safely stores and
decrypt your data on your local device
only using your master password
this means that - Lee never has access
to your personal data and any hacker
would only see random noise - Lane also
autofills your credit card information
whilst online shopping so you can make
purchases without having to fetch your
wallet - Lane has a built-in VPN to
encrypt your data and keep your online
activity anonymous best of all it works
on any device whether you're protecting
your top-secret blueprints to your
quantum supremacy or videos of your cat
there is no better way to make your
online world impenetrable than by using
- Lee for my experience - Lane is the
best all bases covered security and
time-saving tool out there you can try -
Lane for free on your first device by
heading to www.hsn.com forward slash 42
then if you decide you want to upgrade
to premium use my code 42 for 10% off so
if our ability to make more powerful
classical computers is diminishing and
there are still problems out there that
we don't have the tools to solve with
current technology do we just have to
accept
that we're reaching the limits of what
we're capable of as a species actually
no we just need to build a different
kind of computer one that transcends the
natural physical limits of microchips a
quantum one the first thing we should
clear up is that quantum computers are
not simply a newer faster version of
regular computers that means if all you
want to do is watch YouTube and share
memes you're better off hanging onto
your trusty laptop even if a few of the
keys are beginning to stick quantum
computers work in a drastically
different way to regular computers and
they're good at doing different things
just how a lightbulb isn't a better
version of a candle it's a different way
of generating light a quantum computer
isn't a better version of a computer
it's a completely new way of approaching
computation but start with the basics
the fundamental unit of information in a
classical computer is the binary digit
known as a bit these bits have two
possible states either 0 or 1 and
strings of them can be used to encode
information you can think of them as a
series of very simple switches it might
not sound like much but at a fundamental
level bits underpin pretty much every
single thing you do on your computer yes
even that a quantum computer on the
other hand has qubits literally quantum
bits instead of regular bits just like
regular bit qubits have two possible
basic states if a 0 or 1 but unlike
regular bits qubits are for want of a
better way of putting it pretty weird in
our classical computers the state of
event is fixed at any given time it's
either 0 or 1
and sure enough qubits have a 0 and 1
state also represented by how they are
aligned within their hosts magnetic
field in quantum mechanics this is
called spin and the 2 possible states
are spin up and spin down but
there is a magical third state well it's
actually not a state at all it is to put
it in lay language a combination of both
known States
you see whilst a quantum computer is
operating the state of each qubit is
undefined there is some probability of
each qubit being a 1 and some
probability of it being a 0 this one
defines state is known as a quantum
superposition where it can be considered
to be in both spin up and spin down at
the same time and only when we observe
the system will a superposition collapse
and the qubit will settle on one of its
two basic states
it's an odd concept but many of you will
have come across it before in famous
feline torturer her windrow ting his
force experiment known as Schrodinger's
cat before we open the box the cat is
neither alive nor dead but is in a
superposition of the two only when we
open the box and observe the cat is it
one or the other
explaining exactly how quantum
superposition makes quantum computers so
powerful would take several textbooks a
boatload of muffs a theoretical physics
education that I don't possess and an
exploration of some other weird quantum
phenomena like quantum entanglement or
spooky action at a distance as Einstein
called it but the general concept is
this a classical computer can only be in
one basic state at a time that means
when joins itself a problem like crime
factoring
where there are many potential solutions
to sort through broadly speaking it must
check each solution one after the other
but when a qubit is in a superposition
it's able to process huge numbers of
classical States in parallel which
allows it to do certain kinds of
calculations exponentially faster than a
classical computer code Erik Clara's
insky co-founder of the quantum
computing company d-wave explains it
like this
imagine that you only have five
minutes to find an X written on the page
of a single book amongst 50 million of a
books in the Library of Congress if you
search for the X like a regular computer
one page at a time you would never find
it before your five minutes are up but
if you had 50 million parallel realities
and you could look at a different book
in each of those realities you would
find the X much much faster in this
second example a quantum computer splits
you into 50 million versions of yourself
to make the work quick and easy and you
may think but we've had parallel
computing for over 50 years one of the
big to retailed micro process of
manufacturers AMD sells a CPU that has
64 cores and you can slot it right into
your home desktop computer with the
right motherboard and the videos latest
GPU can compute almost 5,000 problems in
parallel why don't we just keep
improving these existing technologies
well because of the atomic level
physical size limits of transistors that
we touched on earlier
we're quickly nearing the limit of how
much further we can push this
parallelism unless we change the rules
of the game we'll never reach the
aforementioned 50 million parallel
processors of a quantum computer using
classical computing hardware because
adding more cores to a classical
computer system increases its power
linearly providing the software can take
full advantage of each core of course
conversely with quantum computers with
each qubit you add to the system the
amount of parallel processors you can
run increases exponentially
so with two qubits you can consider for
potential outcomes at once but with four
qubits you can consider sixteen
if you were to pack just 300 cubits into
a quantum computer it could consider
more variables at once than there are
particles in a known universe now that's
what I call parallel computing now it's
possible that you might be feeling a tad
confused right about now if so that's
awesome
you're probably getting it after all
richard fineman the man who originated
the idea of the quantum computer in the
first place once said if you think you
understand quantum mechanics
you don't understand quantum mechanics
seeing as he went on to win the Nobel
Prize for his work in quantum mechanics
it's a safe bet he knew what he was
talking about when he claimed he didn't
know what he was talking about okay so
all of this sounds great
but what can we actually use quantum
computers for earlier on I mentioned
that quantum computers are much much
better than classical computers at
finding the prime factors of very large
numbers which is a foundational
principle in data encryption and digital
security it's been estimated that a
classical computer would take trillions
of years to crack RSA's 2048 encryption
which is commonly used to secure data
transmission online a quantum computer
on the other hand could do so in a
matter of hours effectively rendering
modern online security obsolete but
before you withdraw all your money from
the bank and start shoveling it under
your mattress
don't worry digital security has always
been an arms race and in this case the
good guys have a pretty big head start
on the bat post quantum encryption
methods are already being developed that
will be able to thwart even quantum
computers though admittedly implementing
them will still require a radical
redesign of the way encryption works
online think something along the lines
of fixing the Millennium book a mythical
insect that if you are any younger than
I am you've probably never heard of but
don't worry it turned out to be rather
harmless in the end beyond Internet
Security
there are many theoretical applications
for quantum could be
plans are already in place to use
quantum computers to create wildly
powerful AIS by supercharging the
machine learning process with quantum
algorithms the downside of course is
that these AIS will one day rise up and
destroy us but in the last few seconds
before we're finally exterminated we'll
all be able to take great pride in how
clever we were to come up with quantum
computers in the first place
quantum computers are also
unsurprisingly extremely good at
simulating quantum physics itself this
was in fact the original application
Fineman had in mind when he came up with
the concept since the complexities
involved make this an area unsuited to
classical computers classical computers
are so inaccurate when it comes to
physics that all existing models broadly
approximates the in vastly simplify
terms rules of the universe which isn't
tremendously useful to scientists but
with quantum computers able to model
immensely complex interactions at the
particle level we will be able to make
huge advances in designing new trucks
materials solar cells high-temperature
superconductors as well as many other
niche was incredibly impactful in use
cases such as modeling chemical
catalysts for use in making better
fertilizers quantum computers will also
help us perfect the optimization of
complex systems like traffic flow and
logistics problems on a massive scale
we'll be able to accurately model
national and global financial systems
with currently impossible levels of
granularity and complexity which could
either be used to highlight financial
weak points and level up society or
predict what the markets will do next
and make the banks even richer only time
will tell but I'm betting on the last
okay so quantum computers are going to
be awesome
we seem to know exactly what they're
going to look like and how they would
work so why haven't we just made one
already well it turns out they're
actually pretty tricky to put together
qubits themselves are typically made
from subatomic particles like photons or
electrons firstly you have to isolate
them and to get them to reliably perform
the weird [ __ ] we talked about earlier
you need to make them very very cold and
we aren't talking oh it's a bit chilly
in here maybe I'll put a jumper on cold
we're talking literally colder than the
nut shriveling darkest reaches of outer
space cold in fact it's a balmy 2.7
Kelvin outer space looks like a tropical
holiday compared to what's required to
run a quantum computer just 0.01 5
Kelvin that's about minus 273 degrees
Celsius to those of you who don't speak
science or to put it another way almost
as cold as it is physically possible to
make something in our universe that's
being zero Kelvin or absolute zero even
at this temperature qubits are very
unstable and prone to decoherence which
occurs when the surrounding environment
interacts with them and errors are
introduced to the system all things
considered attempting to make a quantum
computer presents a vast engineering
challenge and requires monumental
amounts of cash which is why the good
guys will have a huge head start in
developing new quantum security
protocols it could be a further decade
or more before this monumentally
challenging technology trickles down to
your everyday basement hacker and it
just so happens that there is one entity
out there with some pretty nifty
engineers and
very deep pockets who actually have made
a working quantum computer already just
last year Google claimed to have
achieved something called quantum
supremacy with their 54 qubit quantum
computer called Sycamore quantum
supremacy is not as it sounds racism
against regular computers what is
defined as a quantum computer completing
a computation that no classical computer
could match in a reasonable amount of
time google claims sycamore ran a random
sampling calculation in 200 seconds
something they say would take the most
powerful classical computers available
today around 10,000 years admittedly IBM
did come along the very next day to piss
on the quantum barbeque by claiming
their supercomputer sumit could complete
that task in 2.5 days but that is still
significantly longer than sycamore talk
about a thousand times longer
in fact and all with just 54 qubits so
why didn't you hear about this literal
quantum leap forward for humanity that's
a good question but then many of the
most influential inventions in history
have been underappreciated to begin with
today there are tens of billions of
light bulbs in use around the world but
when Thomas Edison and his team invented
this new and improved version of the
candle that wasn't a candle leading
scientist Henry Morton of the Stevens
Institute of Technology
predicted it would be a conspicuous
failure and the British government felt
it was unworthy of the attention of
practical or scientific men quantum
computers are still very much in their
infancy but they are absolutely already
here and though the full implications
likely won't be understood for some time
to come
one thing's for sure
they will most definitely change the
world
thank you for watching thanks for
watching it thanks again - - ly don't
forget to check them out using the link
below